it's a three-step process and all the
steps are tedious
appreciate your patience
all right and our linkedin stream is
live
let's get started
and welcome to our expert webinar seven
mistakes and seven lessons
journey to data leadership
our speaker today is vijay rajandram
dr rajandram is the founder and ceo of
data that matters llc
and a little bit more about him in a
minute we are also joined by mohan
george
product group who talking with us later
about
a new program we're introducing to
trains cdo's so
it's an exciting program with imperial
college london and we'll hear about that
more in a little bit first
a little more about vj um
he has served his cdf to various firms
he has more than 20 years of experience
product development digital
transformation analytics and various
other data leadership roles
worked from startups all the way up to
the fortune 500
and understands how
ai and ml are impacting
data and data governance
all that we're merging into so
welcome uvj
and before we
start our conversation here is a poll
for the audience
i'm going to ask
us to get a feel
what's your current job role
i think there's an actual
another option there below
uh
bottom list instead of other there's
also other data roles so include that in
your list if
f for other data role g for other if you
are watching on linkedin you put this in
comments
you're watching on youtube saying
the second question second part question
is how are you feeling today we do a
check in with
folks
we have been during the pandemic make
sure that the people are
being resilient to all the
lockdowns and surges and everything else
that's coming our way over the last
couple of years
and
we will
show the results here
and
about half the audience falls into the
other category
and then other data roles
analysts managers
um and
at the director level
there's a few data scientists in our
audience as well
so with that
let's move on
and my name is stuart creek by the way
i'm a marketing manager here at simply
learn
and
what we're going to discuss with your pj
uh are
some mistakes that that
he wants to point out from from his
history and his career
and
the lessons he learned from them so
um this is a quick list but i'm going to
be asking him about each of these
individually so welcome vijay thank you
very very much for being here
and i'm going to um
take this down and we'll just have our
conversation
thanks stuart for inviting me here again
uh really excited to be here
yeah um so this is not a uh name and
shame
um session where you're going to use any
company names or or
talk about playing it's about
talking about how to learn from
fast failure and
agile
techniques that you've used throughout
your career as you've learned to be a
better
uh data leader right
that's right that's right it's uh it's
very humbling to be able to share my my
personal mistakes
over the many years with 100 people 100
over people so now i'm looking for i'm
looking forward to it
okay
um so
when we talk about your your
journey
you start at the very earliest years
you you find you're interested in data
and
you want to get into the field of data
and
what's one of the the early mistakes
that you made when you were just
beginning in this field
i i think well a lot of people fall into
a career data i would say accidentally
um it's actually something quite easy to
pick up because it's you know very
logical programming is very logical
and data is used in in so many places so
you know people accidentally fall um
into this line of work
um from all sorts of um disciplines
actually and
one of the things i find is you come in
a lot of us learn uh how to program and
code organically
you know through books or test and learn
beautiful code is like art you know it's
um it's um it takes a bit of discipline
and and learning to to kind of refine
that and beautiful art you know will
inspire other people to create you know
journeys even just looking at the way
you write code
so i would kind of say i mean i rushed
into it pretty quickly
i rushed into uh trying to solve
business problems straight away i'm not
saying that that's wrong that's good to
understand the business side of it but
it's also important to appreciate the
complexity of you know coding and
writing good code
and learning the foundations right um
you know there were many projects um
that i would i would have accelerated
the coding side of it to get to an
answer um i would feel sorry now
thinking the person who took over my
code you know my jsc
at that time to try and fix or expand
that right uh to go further so
today you have many courses out there
that's available and it's very easy to
learn and get so it's a bit like driving
right you know you pick a lot of bad
habits that sometimes it's good to just
make sure that you know you get a good
foundation that you can build upon
and one of the things that
that i know that
people starting in their careers want to
do whenever you go into a
new situation
there's two ways to approach it one is
to to hang back
and
just listen
because either you're
afraid to put yourself out there or
you aren't quite sure how you're going
to be accepted but the other extreme of
that is
to start contributing really fast to try
to show off
how much of a great contributor you are
and sometimes that doesn't work out so
well
yeah no i completely agree i mean even
though we are all on this journey
and there's no real rush you know this
is good a long career and a data career
can take you in so many different parts
and so many doors open so it's no real
rush really it's good to go to get some
of the foundations right and and really
much later on as you get into more
leadership roles you know you really
appreciate you know um the importance of
getting some of the basics right yeah
so that humility when you're when you're
starting off and saying to yourself
yes i just finished
education training
i know a lot
but i don't know everything
i especially don't know everything about
the organization i'm
it's always good to have that humility
and like you said get the basics right
before you
uh
push too hard but
then um
in the second career mistake when you
look at
the other eagerness
or the the kind of myth that people
build up in their heads is
i can build
the solution i've gone to the users i've
got gotten their
requirements and i'm
contact
with them constantly and i have empathy
for their needs
and
i'm going to build
the application that solves all their
problems
um
what do you say to that
yeah i think in you know
data steel people can apply things you
know their skills to solve lots of
different problems
and i think you go into this mode that
you know taking on more work actually is
not that difficult um i've never known a
data team
that has got little to do right you know
uh getting work
is actually very easy to do but getting
the right work you know and tackling the
right problems is actually it takes
quite quite a skill set you know and
one of the common mistakes i see people
is you know trying to solve everything
and trying to evolve a solution to try
and solve everything right so yeah you
might have started off trying to build a
a house for a you know a family of four
and ended up building a big clubhouse
you know with the ten with tennis courts
and other things and it kind of loses
the original purpose and it becomes kind
of vague on what you're trying to solve
for and there's so much data today that
you just end up getting lost right one
specific area
that i see often come up is you know
automation you know the subject of ai is
so popular
every data team i know are trying to
automate you know manual tasks
um i i learned from you know a great uh
ceo
of a fortune 500 company i remember him
saying to me quite clearly he said
vijay i i don't you know i want you to
automate the right things because you
know there's just so much to automate
and he doesn't get many people coming to
him and saying hey we can cut down
recruitment or you know reduce head
count and things you know so there are
right parts of the business that can
automate at scale and you can change
business models and save money at scale
but if you try and get lost and try and
solve everything and automate everything
um
you know it's hard to then kind of prove
value because all of these things takes
time
and you know um naturally data people
like to solve problems and the more
obvious it is when you can kind of
convert a manual task
to you know automate it you know they
tend to get hooked on it so what i would
say is you know think carefully on
exactly what you're trying to solve for
um you know at the beginning
yeah
and automation
you know
works best for things that are
completely repetitive
sometimes
human insight is not completely
repetitive so
you try to to automate them
certain aspects of decision making that
really aren't
a machine learning problem they're a
human insight problem
but then there's there's another aspect
of
the one solution to rule the world you
know it's like the one ring to rule them
all
um is that
over time you encounter more and more
people the users come back to you with
more requirements or another user group
wants to get in on it
and
you find that you're kind of tacking on
additional
rooms to this house
in san jose california there's a famous
location called the winchester mystery
house
where mrs winchester
inherited a fortune from her husband who
manufactured rifles
and she felt that
to appease the spirits of the people
killed by the rifles
she had to keep building her house and
as long as she kept building her house
she would be fine and she would continue
to live a long life
and the house ends up with
you know over a hundred rooms and things
like stairways that go to blank walls
and
it's it's just an amazing edifice
and it's beautiful to look at but
it
a lot of it just doesn't make any sense
so i bring that up to say
you know if you're building a solution
and then you find that people are coming
to add up and ask you to add on more and
more
um you know how do you resist the
temptation to do that and how do you
push back and say
you know let's think of a new solution
instead of adding
more to this one
yeah you know
i think there's a place you know you
have to innovate in today's world you
have to innovate otherwise you can't
survive in today's changing climate
right so
um it's important to get the discipline
right on what's a project what's a
finite project with a particular goal in
mind that you're trying to solve within
a certain time
it's also important to set the right uh
agile framework for products and stuff
to kind of evolve and you know ensure
that there's a mechanism to kind of
prioritize the backlogs and all of that
stuff yeah and amidst both of these
you also have to kind of encourage
people to innovate you know
you know to some control level right you
know to kind of test out different proof
of concepts and stuff so
it's not that you you've got to fix
things uh but you got to create that
framework to allow that you know it's a
bit like i always refer to these things
as like your retirement investment
portfolios you know you got things that
are high risk glow risk medium risk you
got to make sure that those are all
going in parallel but
trying to solve for everything in one go
in one big lump sum
you tend to lose direction at the end um
and get lost
yeah and
that's a really good
analogy of a
portfolio management approach
uh
of
you know the the things that are risky
need to be done
but you need to balance them with the
things that are essentially
um
fewer bets that
will take you a little bit closer to
your goal so
um
when you start moving up beyond
your early years and you start moving
into middle management
start running into different sets of
challenges right
yeah i you know i think by default
a lot of data leaders you know have kind
of come in from the single contributor
kind of line
uh they're experts in their field and
they're really good at what they do
um they don't naturally kind of you know
learn
team building people development you
know they learn on the job and so kind
of the thing is when you start to get
into middle management you start to
scale
and i mean the example we just spoke
about portfolio management you you'll
find very quickly that you can't do
everything by yourself you know
i find a lot of data folks um who have
their hands in a lot of the pies
um which is okay but you know you need
to kind of make sure that there's the
right delegation and prioritization and
again
giving your people the opportunity to
kind of build on some of those so that
you can start to scale so in today's
world especially data's so complex
there's so many different areas of
expertise
um i try and stay close to advancements
in the area through people
there's no way i am going to be the
expert in all of them
uh and therefore you know making sure
that you know your team knows what is it
that you're trying to solve for uh
that's really important and getting
those parameters right you know we
talked about the buckets of low raised
sky rays medium risk if you can kind of
give them that that kind of structure
your team will kind of surprise you so
one of the common things you know i
struggled with this when i first entered
middle management is to let go
and kind of think you know the teams are
going to start showing you things that
you don't even know right and accepting
that and then that's going to make you
grow in different ways ways that you
don't you didn't even imagine before
yeah that's a really good point in that
you're you're not um
operating a set of puppets
you're empowering a set of people to use
their skills their talents their
insights
to
contribute to the the whole team
so
that's a
a great point
there's also an anecdote from
a man named david olgieldy who started
an advertising agency 1940s 1950s
and
he built it to one of the biggest and
most important ad agencies in the world
to his
dying day as he continued on in
various roles at the company
he would give a gift to each new
employee of a russian
matrushka doll which is the nesting doll
you open it up and there's another doll
inside and another and another
and at the very center there would be a
fortune like from a fortune cookie which
would say
if we hire people less than ourselves we
will become a company of dwarves if we
hire
people
greater than ourselves we will become a
company of giants
so you have to be
as you say willing to look for people
who have
skills and talents you don't have and
not be
afraid that they're going to outshine
you but instead
be glad that they're bringing that to
your team yeah
that's right that's right
that's when you grow at scale you know
at different levels you know you
diversify you know um yeah
so so then
you want to find these people
and you're in a
position you're
moving up in the management structure
you're being given bigger projects
the the environment is changing so data
is becoming more important than it ever
has been
and now management is saying
we need you to do more and more and more
and
what's the
pitfall around
trying to scale up your team too quickly
yeah you know hiring is such an
important part of any data leadership
role
the further up you go
you know
you spend significant time you know 50
percent of my time typically you know
spent at
hiring new people or constantly
integrating them within the team itself
because you can't just hire somebody
bring them in and then you know um let
them automatically integrate with the
team you know there's a lot of effort
required to make sure everything gels
um
you know it's
it's it's normal when you kind of start
budgets and things and then suddenly you
find you know you having to recruit
hundreds of people within short spans of
time the first thing is to kind of know
that tiring takes time because you got
to go through and make sure that
not only you get the right skill set but
the skill set aligns to what you're
trying to do
and also people kind of you know um
you know you have you have to build a
diverse team right everybody brings a
slightly different skill set so finding
people that complement each other in a
wider group is really really important
and and as you're bringing that in
the best way i find to do that is to
encourage your entire team to kind of
get involved because the more your own
people are encouraging their colleagues
and you know to apply for these roles um
you know the the most certain you can be
you're doing the right thing you're
getting the 360 feedback you're
iterating you can't you know you're
bound to get things wrong and stuff it's
better to create that kind of culture
and everybody's recruiting right you
know uh and and making sure that you
bring them on
and you spend a lot of time integrating
you know them in in the teams um i'm not
sure stuart if you're a big soccer fan
i'm a big liverpool supporter fan um we
had an unfortunate weekend obviously
this this weekend for those who follow
soccer but
but you know they bring in some
superstars into the team but sometimes
you see they don't really play regularly
for three to six months you know because
they're trying to get them into the team
and they're trying to make sure that
they can play with each other and stuff
and when you look at them
you know they play you know wearing the
jerseys bigger than their individual
skill set itself right so
you know i kind of common mistakes that
i've made personally is sometimes you
get caught up with too many projects and
the speed of just hiring people and then
you know you actually end up spending
more time
trying to rectify you know things where
you've hired the wrong person uh and you
have to course correct uh it becomes
difficult right you know to to kind of
do that so i i would say hiring for me
is you're always hiring people you know
it's not only when you have a job spec i
constantly try and meet new people um
and every time i see an exciting person
you know who i make sure that i stay
connected with them and today's social
media network is out there to kind of
help with this right and even if it's
not a job right now it might be for a
job later um and so that hiring whole
process it's a constant process not not
only when you have an open uh open job
description
yeah and that makes sense and
as you said it's not just a matter of
you know if you're
if you have a child and they play with
lego bricks you can buy
bulk lego bricks and the bricks fit
together and you know they all fit
together and the child can make whatever
they want out of them
and it doesn't really matter
um
you know there's no individual character
to the bricks other than their size and
shape
but um
people aren't like that
you can you know
go ahead you know just i was just saying
that in today's pandemic world people
want more
from their jobs right you're spending
significant amount of time in in work
they don't want it to be transactional
when you've got a job spec and you just
got to do a mechanical task right you
know
um bring data in you know clean data up
you know it's it's not that they want
much more than that in today's world so
you know i think building relationships
over the long term is really really
important with people
and
as
i think as you pointed out
you want to um
understand their individual capabilities
and put them into the right roles so
that you're getting the
the advantage of that capability and not
just having it sit idle while they're
doing some other entirely different kind
of work
that's right that's right and you know
seeing other people succeed
is a good measure of your own success
you know getting other people to kind of
succeed
yeah
um
so you move from
the middle level and you start moving
into
the upper echelons
um
what is one of the i mean
you talk about a high failure rate among
cdos and what's one of the first
traps or pitfalls that they encounter
when they start getting up to that level
i think especially
you're coming through you know middle
management into the leadership role
um
you know in in middle management you
often find yourself practicing things
over and over and again right you kind
of try and get things right you know you
you try and over prepare yourself to get
things right
and sometimes you forget you know um
mistakes are gonna happen you know um
one the other right as you step into a
leadership role
you really have got to give and build a
safe environment for people to take some
risks
and and fail
you know if you don't create that
culture um and prepare for that
it's hard to kind of innovate
uh and you know you don't get past that
safety you know that safe environment
for everybody to kind of go you know i
can try new things i can develop stuff
into areas that i don't even know about
right so
i mean i've in the past you know as you
get further up the chain in terms of a
leadership role you get bigger and
bigger projects and you know there's
bigger
delivery impacts if you don't deliver
right in my experience you know i did a
large uh migration of live systems with
millions of customers and you know the
the the the error percentage you know
you've got to minimize that right
because you're trying to swap in a split
second turn an old system off and turn
the new system on right
you know i remember trying to be over
prepared
months and months of training of it
and then i realized that we actually got
it wrong and we got a very simple thing
wrong at the end but
what i learned from that is
it's just as important to kind of
prepare for a team to kind of
troubleshoot without knowing what area
that is because that's what's gonna hit
you and how are you gonna react right to
that uh and and find a new solution that
you might not even have practiced and
that's becoming more and more important
right when you think about data
governance you know uh data security
today you know the all sorts of things
happening out there
you have to have your team kind of
prepared to kind of learn how to solve
that fast problem solving skill is
really important to kind of um have in
your team and embed that you know kind
of culture yeah i mean there are two
principles from
warfare that uh
that
address this kind of
problem this dilemma
first is the the saying that no plan
survives first contact with the enemy
meaning that as you said you can prepare
you can plan you can
anticipate every contingency and then
when you
go to execute that plan
something will happen that you didn't
foresee or something that you
intend to do one way is just not going
to work the way you envisioned it and
you need to be able
to then
pivot to something else and that the
the other aspect is the agility and the
ability of
people on the so-called front lines
people
who work for you on your team
to have the
the
independence and the authority from you
to say okay this is a problem
i can solve it at my level rather than
having to wait until
a manager two levels up or the cdo
comes up with a solution people need to
be able to
adapt improvise and overcome this is the
expression that's used so
that's a
uh
important aspect especially in a world
where
the third concept i'll mention is the
fog of war the there's an old
expression about how you can't always
know what's going on you can't see what
the enemy is doing you can't
see beyond
you know a certain range and you have to
be prepared for whatever comes and
anticipate any possibility and that
pretty much describes the world we're in
where technology is changing so quickly
that we don't know what the next
set of skills and what the next
technology
is going to be that we need to have
and we need to therefore prepare
ourselves to be agile and flexible in
that regard
that's right
absolutely right
um so when you talk
about the failure rate of cds
what's the number that you cite
it's typically i think um you know
there's a there's a report out there
that says 50
uh of cdos are poised for success you
know
it's one of the reasons you find a lot
of short tenures in in cdos
um
so yeah i mean mainly a lot of it is
attributed to um unclear goals because
it's so wide
uh different um companies are different
stages of their maturity
um and therefore it's quite a wide area
yeah
and so the things we're talking about
today are
ways to be in the
50 that are prepared for success
rather than the 50 percent that don't
quite cut it but um
one of the the areas that we talked
about previously was
and you just touched on it
is making sure that what you're doing is
aligned to the goals of
the team
the organization the business
and
what are some of the problems that can
come up
when you have a misalignment there
how does that come how does that come
about
yeah i think you know if you look at a
lot of chief data officer roles today
if you read a lot of the the roles you
know uh it's the responsibilities that
are spelt out are kind of mechanical
right most cdos know that they have to
have good knowledge of how to get
architecture right they have to have
good knowledge of you know data
transformation tools you know people
build leadership skills collaboration
and so on right but you know most of the
time you go into a cbo role you have a
large range of stakeholders right or
partners i'd say i won't even call them
stakeholders because you're jointly
involved in trying to solve this you
know you'll be partnering with the the
chief executive officer the cfo the
chief marketing officer the chief risk
officer chief digital officer the chief
information officer so there are many
different people
uh in in this and you have to work quite
closely
and because data cuts across in so many
areas you know
the lines are blurred between different
roles as well
and that's okay it's absolutely okay
i think the key is how do you align
you know everybody's objectives to solve
for this right just like we started off
earlier to say there are different
buckets
high risk media risk low risk i come
back to the same portfolio management
you have to tackle everything
um but you've also got a finite set of
resources while you're trying to grow
the team and so on right so the key is
where do you put those percentages of
efforts and what are you trying to do
and getting alignment across the whole
c-suite
is super super important and
you know i've spoken to
many mentors who've kind of told me you
know if you want to get something done
collaboratively you allowing people's
remuneration i i kind of agree that and
sometimes you know we have
different ways people kind of fill up
you know performance management goals or
people have okr's objective key results
today
and and people go further and say well
some of these we need to find a way to
kind of tie them to
their remuneration right so you
physically feel it
personally i feel there's a level that
you need to go beyond that right
everybody takes up these roles mostly
quite successful
and most of them care right they can't
you know most of them care about the
business about the people the key is to
go beyond that and get to know them and
work as a team to kind of go why are
these people in the roles take time to
understand that and actually try and gel
and try and make each other successful
and know what what takes right because
there are items that
you're going to be quite um focused on
to kind of uh to do in a certain way
there but there are items you just have
to give up and say okay you know what i
might not agree with it but i'm going to
trust you and i'm going to go with you
and i'm going to support you because
it's equally important for our joint
success right so
that collaborative nature is really
important and aligning that and finding
that you know how do you make them tick
right so i mean one will be talking
about this a bit more about the course
we're doing you know uh uh later on but
a lot of this is about leadership and in
building high performing teams together
it's not just about technical nature
right it's knowing about you know what
to to let go is equally important to
know what to let go versus what to
actually implement successfully
yeah
and and
that's a great point in the sense that
yes you want to make sure that people's
compensation
is tied to their goals on a certain
level
but you want to make sure that that's
not the only
dimension that you're using
to get people to understand their role
in the organization their role in the
team
the
nature of their contribution
and
the value of
teamwork and
sometimes when
your compensation says i should be doing
this but your teammate is over here
struggling with that
sometimes the needs of the of the team
and therefore your ultimate success as a
contributor
requires that you take some time away
from what you're
being quote unquote paid to do and go
off and help the other person
so that they can do their part to make
you successful as well so
that type of
collaboration and teamwork
goes beyond
you know what you what you can
necessarily measure in
a bonus or a
paycheck
completely and you know i think it's
it's really important i've seen
um lots of companies do
you know profiling
uh mice breaks they're different things
that are great now and kind of showing
you know where you fit in a type of
profile or persona and how do you get a
very diverse team up together
what i really learned is actually it's
good to go one step beyond that and get
team coaches because this is not a
one-off process where you answer a bunch
of questions and you get put into a box
right the question is
once you get that how do you get then
make it work and how do you kind of make
everybody gel you know to kind of
connect together right
it's important in every sense it's
obviously important to not only do it
with your team
but very important with your
peers as well because that that's where
you you don't have direct influence and
as a leader you got to be equally good
at
um you know working together and
collaborating you know in a matrix type
structure
and
you know the the soft skills of
persuasion and influence are are
very important um yes especially when
you're when you're talking to
um people who
are on your peer level
or people above you in the organization
where
the tool of authority is not going to
help you
yeah
and the skill of reading reading the
room
yeah is a very important skill
uh but you've got multiple people here
and that's why i come back to
you know having team coaches really good
you know to kind of bring people so you
help people read the room together right
so that you can see different
perspectives
yeah
um
so
when you are
in the position of the cdo
you have a lot of responsibility on your
shoulders
and you are
let's take a step back when you're
looking at taking the role of cdo
whether it's within your organization
because you're being asked to step up in
a promotion
or whether you are looking at a new
organization and an opportunity that's
come your way
how do you
assess
your likelihood
of success what what do you need to do
in order to make sure that
you're going to be successful in that
new role
i would really um advise people to take
time
to do due diligence
of the role itself
not so much from just the job spec
perspective right you know and you know
often people will look at the p l s and
look at how the financials are doing and
so on but
i i think that it's really valuable to
spend time going beyond that to kind of
understand the culture of the company on
the ground right on the ground and
really understanding how people
collaborate
you know how people are assigning those
buckets that we talked about right the
medium risk the high risk the the low
risk how are they managing all of that
and trying to juggle right because
that's when you see the real things kind
of coming out and the appetite for that
and really spending time to do that
right and creating those connections
because that's where you're gonna know
whether you're gonna you know this is
gonna uh be right for you or not and
sometimes
you know roles might not be right for
individuals or it might not be right for
the company because the date of maturity
or they're not at the same point in time
with what you're trying to achieve so
there's nobody there's no right or wrong
here is just finding the perfect match
right whether the stars are aligning
so it's really important to get beyond
um just the job spec and unfortunately
most interview processes right it's too
short you know you don't get to know
everything in four or five hours of
meeting you know three four people so uh
if possible take the time to know um um
you know and have a look at things in
action
um and get a feel for it um you know
before before jumping in and making sure
that that's what you want to do and
that's what they need
yeah
if the notion of due diligence and
doing that it's the same
concept as as you use as you described
earlier in
your method of hiring which is to
you know
continue to look for
the fit and then when you
are talking to somebody
you know you you it's
a process of give and take to
understand what they
can do
what they want to do
where their ambitions lie
and match that and communicate to them
what you need them to do
what opportunities you're giving them
where
you can expect
them to go in the organization
and
the same kind of thing applies when
you're on the side of
looking at an opportunity
you've got to understand
what is this opportunity
what is this as you said what is the
state of the company is it in a growth
mode is it in a cost control mode
is it
the kind of company where
things are done in a certain way or is
it the kind of company where
people are given freedom to
explore their own
directions and solutions
and find out you know what's that fit
between you and them
um
over and above
as you described it the mechanical
requirements of
getting the work done and
eating the jobs back and that type of
thing so
yeah
i really emphasize on
all you know there's no right or wrong
answer and you often need a combination
of different things you know whether
you're delivering in a waterfall kind of
project by project basis on agile basis
or you're doing
uh business optimization right within
different business
units itself right or you're doing some
digital transformation type work all of
this is normal that you find in every
company today all of this stuff will be
happening at the same time you will have
regulatory pressures and so on so that's
not a that's a common scenario to get in
right
the key is
how are you going to divide up your time
to make sure that you know you're
connecting all of these pieces together
and that's when that collaboration and
you know appetite kind of comes in the
clearer you can make that the better it
is for all parties
great
um i think we're reaching a point now
where
you know
what would you what would you summarize
or or what kind of
overall takeaways should people take
from this discussion and your
experiences
um
so that they can benefit from
your mistakes and learn those lessons
um
without having to make too many of those
mistakes themselves
um
well the first thing i would say is to
be brave to make mistakes you know
you have to take risks in a data career
i find that because of the logical
thinking the way most data people are
they tend to not want to take risks too
much sometimes
and i think you should be brave to make
them to explore
but then really acknowledge them when
they happen right you know a lot of
these seven mistakes that i've shared
today
i made those mistakes and some of those
some of those mistakes
might have not been mistakes at certain
types of company at a different maturity
level as well you know so whatever it is
it's it might not be suitable for that
place at that time right so it's
important to acknowledge them
and then the most important thing is
what are you going to do differently
next time you know when you kind of come
in you know in a similar situation or a
slightly different how do you learn and
act differently so
it's it's a it's going to continue to be
a very vague space because of the the
different hats that a cdo wears
i would kind of say be brave to to to
venture out there make mistakes and
learn from them
great
that's
that's such an important piece of advice
because
so many of
us
when you make a mistake and you find out
that it didn't work out
you say well that
then i failed
and
the
message you should take away from that
is yes you failed you learned a way to
not to do it right
that eliminates one of the possibilities
now go try something else and if you
fail again you've eliminated another one
of the ways not to do it right and
ultimately you'll get there that's the
expression that thomas edison used when
he described
the process of uh
inventing and improving the light bulb
was uh yes i i tried this a thousand
times and 990
times it didn't work but those weren't
failures those were
ways i found that
to not do it right so
when i found the 1000th way
i knew it would work so
this is the same kind of process that
you use in your career you
fail you learn you grow from it
so with that let's let's move on to some
questions and answers we have
a number that have come in from the
audience and
when you talk about the basics and
foundation marine asks
what
are the basics and foundations of
somebody um
should be looking to acquire if they're
not necessarily especially if they're
not from a technical
or data background
if um
i would kind of say that have a look at
the list of
of uh programs out there today i mean
simply learn do some amazing programs
have a look at some of the modules of
start off with the simple ones like the
data analysts um you know uh modules
and you know it kind of goes through and
talks about how to analyze data you know
fundamentals of coding and stuff come
from a coding perspective but also
coming in from the business side as well
and what are you analyzing and stuff so
it's good to kind of look at some of
those course modules
and and try and do some of these courses
right there plenty of out there uh some
of them comes with certain
certifications i would really advise
people to look at what's out there and
build a story that connects all these
certifications together right to give
you that great bandwidth to not only
know how to do a particular vertical
of data well but also what are your
hand-off points right because you're
never working alone if you're going to
be a data engineer you're going to be
working with an analyst and you're going
to be working with an architect so what
is those hand-off points right so it's
important to get and appreciate that
and take advantage of what's out there
today
so odinio
asks
is it necessary to learn data analysis
data science big data engineering
become a data expert
you need all of those different
components in your background
most
data folks when you kind of look at them
for you know for two to three years
experience
you would typically expect them to know
one or two coding languages
almost all of them are expected to know
sql in some shape or form at least to
interrogate data and then they might be
combining that with the python or r
uh using different tool sets you know
data breaks and so on but you'd expect
them to know
um
so and you'd expect them to know how to
analyze data at least so once you get to
the two to three years so
you kind of have to get your hands dirty
a little bit and especially where we're
going even the more and more tools out
there which are no code you know kind of
environments right that you don't need
to know coding you can kind of use
visuals to kind of link up stuff but to
be honest it's not that difficult to
pick it up um and you're bound to kind
of i know a lot of people who just
picked it up on the job so i would say
it is important to at least know some
fundamentals
maybe
there's a there's a lot of depth you can
go in
but you might not need to go into that
level of depth depending on which path
you choose but you need some
foundational elements yes okay
um
we have
congruently who
asks
about a related topic uh
just a little off topic he's he's
looking to get into ai and ml
uh as a career area
and
is curious to know what are the skill
sets
that people need to have in order to be
very successful in that field
i would say
the first thing i know a lot of people
want to get into ai and ml
the first thing is actually do some good
reading up on what is the definition of
ai and ml because i i think you know
there's a lot of noise in the industry
and what it actually is
and people are confused between
you know how does a uh a credit score
card that built the fico score
defer to a machine learning kind of
algorithm and so on right so it's good
to kind of do some good reading up or
link up with the right people to know
what are the difference between all of
this equally important is i would kind
of say
focus and zoom in on an area and go what
are you trying to solve for what is the
business problem that you're trying to
solve for
and and get excited about something
right and it's really important to
connect those two pieces because i see a
lot of people who do
um
ai machine learning you know for the
sake of it you know without having a
purpose it's very difficult to be a very
general general uh piece so i would
advise
get the purpose right get a problem that
you like to solve or one that you you
want to be involved in
and and know what it actually
is okay
um
so
we have a person who asks about
health care as an industry
and
somebody
especially who's taking on a data
leadership role in that business how do
you
how
can that person tying use the existing
um how can
i enable data-driven culture in this new
organization
as the head of data and of insights how
to support
the initiative to build and grow
data-driven objectives
so that's a an interesting question how
how does one
introduce a data perspective in a data
orientation into an organization
got it i think you know it's really
important
i mean healthcare is a huge area right
now that's got many many data roles
um i mean healthcare in fact you know
one of the early adopters of data you
know in terms of running clinical trials
and all of those things
a long long time ago and now there's a
lot of digital transformation happening
in the healthcare industry as well
because we're trying to make healthcare
more affordable to people you know um
more virtual visits to kind of get some
of the
the prescriptive prescriptions and so on
so i would say
it really depends because different um
you know companies are different stages
of the maturity but i actually think the
healthcare is pretty advanced right now
in the data space
my advice would be to still create those
three buckets right what is the what are
the business operations that are already
taking place today
you know map those things out in terms
of what what what's happening on the
ground data obviously you'll have data
activities within that but know what
they are and how much you can help you
then have another bucket that kind of
says okay how are we going to transform
the business or diversify there will be
some digital uh transformation going on
create those and start to see what are
the things you can change at scale right
like completely going to virtual visits
because you want to make something
completely affordable right or you might
kind of think about what are the things
that we've got paperwork that we can use
you know aiml to automate right and have
an offshore operation center to kind of
do all of that stuff you know uh in an
automated fashion
uh i would build those up and then kind
of see okay where is the company right
now
in their trajectory and then map out the
activities that you have to build out
and then show according to benchmarks of
other companies right like how are they
doing in those spaces
we have a question
um
and the person didn't leave his name i
think but
the question what is the best thing
in your opinion about being part of the
data science industry
you know um
i love having data to prove something or
back it up you know
it's it's if it gives me extra
confidence when i can come and actually
say to people okay here's the story
right of your hypothesis you know you
may have a hypothesis about a business
or a proposition or something that
you're trying to build a product or
services
i really get excited when i can kind of
prove that or show the story being built
up with you know data backing that up
right not only telling what's gonna
happen
but also starting to build out some
um some projections right and this is
where you could do go-to uh if you do
these following things right so for me
the storytelling part of data and
backing it up with data is the most
exciting part of this whole field
gonna ask the audience for some feedback
on
the the seven areas we talked about
and let me open this quick poll
and uh fortunately i won't be able to
put it up on the screen here but
basically we're going back to
um
oops
sorry
as you're filling out the poll
we're going back to these
which correspond to abcdefg for the
poll
so
[Music]
you have a couple seconds get your
answers in
and i'll share with you the result now
we asked what are the two most
interesting or important
areas out of the ones we discussed
and the two top answers 56 percent of
people said delegation and
prioritization that challenge is the
most
important
along with due diligence
and assessing risks
so those are two areas did you have any
final thoughts on those
i
i would say they are pretty pretty
important those two things they set the
kind of rhythm of a lot of things
because you can't you know
do things single-handedly so building
the team is super important and due
diligence to kind of get the right
reward risk and reward you know balance
is super critical i i'd agree with that
okay and we have an off
line poll so to speak
um that is
available to everyone and the
i'm going to put into the chat this
bitly link
we'd like you to take a moment to do
this survey which gives us an idea of
who's in the audience and who might be
interested in the
imperial college london program that uh
vijay and
mohan are about to speak about
so if you would
go to that link at some point
and fill in that survey that would be
helpful
um
sorry
want to give you also vijay's
linkedin
contact information so that you can
keep in touch with him
and i'm going to put that into the chat
as well
and
now i'm going to give vijay and mohan a
chance to talk about
the program that's coming up with
imperial college london
so
i want you to
discuss the important points of this
program
mohan you want to kick it off
uh yes thank you vijay thank you
uh hi everyone i hope you had a great
time listening to the insights from mr
vijay on
his journey to become a data leader
and thanks for taking your time out for
this webinar
and we're happy and proud to announce
that sinclair has partnered with
immediate college london which is one of
the most prestigious universities in the
world
to release a course on chief data
officer
and i hope all who joined this
particular session you had a great
interest on this particular topic
and you are aspiring to become a chief
data officer in your career
and to support that we have launched
this particular program
which will be
like a 15-week program
and it is
delivered by the professors from
imperial college london
and
there will be a lot of master classes
which will be live and interactive as
well
and as mr vijay said
building relationships is one of the
most important aspect in your life
and by joining this program you will be
getting to network with the imperial
college alumni network
and you will be interacting with most of
the data officers in and around the
world where you can talk to each other
learn from their experience
and then understand how to take it
forward in your organization
so vijay will share some more details
about the program
over to you vijay
yeah i think the only thing thank you
mohan for that you know it's not it does
touch some of the technical foundation
elements
but you know importantly it also covers
a lot about
communication leadership building how do
you uh build high performing teams and
you know constantly innovating it will
touch all those important elements as
well which is wider than just the
technical elements of of being a
successful chief data officer
thank you so much um
back to you stuart do you want to close
certainly and i want to thank everyone
for being here i'm putting the
survey link again into the
chat so please do
go to that link and answer those
questions there i've also put in the
email for project patra
who is also involved with the the
program
so if you want to learn more about the
icl london
cdo program please
email patrick
pratik i'm sorry
and um
let's
i invite everybody to follow simply
learn on our social media channels which
are
at simply learn on facebook and twitter
and simply learn on linkedin
thank you all for being here thank you
so much vijay and
mohan for
uh being with us today
and thank you vijay for sharing with us
so generously from
your experience
so that people can
learn from
lessons you've taken up from your long
career
with that uh we conclude our webinar for
today so thank you so much and uh if you
have the additional questions that have
come in
um please feel free to contact
us by email i can forward those to
vj
you have
steward at simply learn's email address
and your invitations
uh but also
you can contact
bj through linkedin
and again we look forward to inviting
all of you into the simply learn
learning community so thank you so much
you